und zwar dass es bis nächste woche
freitag friedens phase ist das natürlich
auch wichtig das wusste ich natürlich
schon alles geschieht oder so aber okay
ja gut leute dann alter hut
sondern herzlich willkommen zur ersten
folge des neuen projekts der ersten
folge von yes und es ist so geil ich
habe noch keine minute aufgenommen und
ich hab so bock drauf wir legen direkt
los januar auf den auf den server machen
das mal auf wo ich habe jetzt gerade
hoch sodass klar hat er das kleine
kleine fenster und habe mich auf groß
gemacht aber hoffentlich kategorie riss
nicht ab
ok ja und wie man werde jetzt mal
anfangen dass marius dann locker in der
beschreibung euch mal die regeln erklärt
denn die sind vielfältig sagt ja und
jetzt direkt zum laufen
das ist auch auf 1.457 basiert ja er hat
den sound gehört von den gilt man das
ist richtig krass was kaufen
es gibt so viele geile mops hier und
jetzt 1.4 punkt sieben mini kraft
version
deswegen kann ich nicht mit shift
sprinten und das ist richtig ungewohnt
für mich also ich muss jetzt doch
wirklich sprinten was ich seit monaten
nicht mal gemacht habe aber okay dann
als angewöhnen das paket kann man auch
nicht finden die aber trotzdem das wird
glaube ich eine geile zeit hergibt
meinhof dafür 21
unsere region und zwar
sk deniz fahri und daily mail
und ja es gibt zwei regionen am liebsten
die erste region die betteln sich so
über ich musste heute holen kommt ich
brauch holz hat schon stadt gebaut
das ist der brunnen ja die jungs haben
schon ein kleines bisschen stoff 12
folgen oder so haben die ich hab noch
gar noch gar keine hochgeladen
es war nämlich so gestern abend hat wir
angeblich gerade eine verabredung aber
ich muss die ja mit folien etwas machen
und wasser und milch trinken ein
bisschen wie das ist und da konnte ich
nicht dabei sein deswegen wird heute
nachgereicht sozusagen
und ja das ist jetzt der beginn einer
epischen langen lovestory zwischen mache
es mir egal ich bei unseren unterschlupf
ich schon wieder hunger irgendwo
wichtigste regel ist eigentlich so für
euch wenn man stirbt muss man die
aufnahme abbrechen das wichtigste mann
für zu krass schnell ich bin jetzt schon
bei der hälfte
meine sachen wieder das ziel die folge
ist für mich heute den fan guide zu
machen
ich muss schauen was mein graphics lebst
hier die grafik sind fans ich kann
trotzdem ich das durch die bäume
durchschauen
das haben wir wollen so umgestellt wir
haben gerade noch bis an den
grafikeinstellungen geboxt bisschen
herausgefunden hatten dass ein einfacher
trick gibt eine einfache lösung und
jetzt als wenn die fresse gmbh bitte geh
bitte was zu essen ich habe auch nichts
zu essen
ich musste erst mal wieder raus
da halte ich weiß ernst ich habe nur
noch vier punkte
so was wir jetzt nach ja wieder was zu
essen holen indem er ihnen hier und hier
auf dem boden klatschen das trägt nun
gespannt
ich habe mitbekommen dass kommen egal
ja nochmal zu wolf das ist eine
kombination aus 38 max als 38.000 sachen
die wir zusammen erkunden können
und ja ihr das noch relativ unbekannte
smartpad es heißt die wenigsten wenn
sich dann wahrscheinlich auskennen
trotzdem falsch irgendwelche guten tipps
ab falls ihr wolf schneider gezockt habt
schreibt sie mir jetzt in die kommentare
damit ich bessere tricks machen kann ist
gescheit genau und den begriff ist geil
die wollten die meisten alter nicht
sterben direkt da musste auch gut für
dich gilt das jetzt noch nicht in der
junge der körper die kiste gestellt
brainwash immer dein leben
wenn du klaust schießen da unten einfach
denn der hat ja gerade erst mal ein
deutsches ich habe schon schwer etwas zu
essen klar ja ich wieder auf der suche
nach kühlen weil ich brauch leder und
ich kraft in der zeit mal ein echt blöde
würde man kann auch gar nicht die item
so ziehen beim gepäck gleich das einfach
übel aus ja klar special tricks die man
hier machen muss man kann ich alles
machen aber solo und ja wie lange werden
die folgen zu sein mache immer so waren
im netz
minuten der ist gut ich will ein
bisschen holz manstein schwertwale alter
es gibt so viele krasse moxie lottes
müsst ihr euch geben
es gibt wahre es gibt krabbeln und es
gibt so unfassbar viel zu entdecken das
ist schon wirklich übel hoffen nur dass
alles gut bei mir doch keinen
schilderwald jetzt am main abonnenten
anschlag märz an die kommentare aber ich
bin das mit shader irgendwie schöner und
bin ich eigentlich alter
ich war ganz so brenner wir sind so
viele hühner aber keine kühne
ich war ganz so böse brehna falter ich
habe einfach gerade mal okay ich habe
einfach gerade mal
ich wollte eine spitzenkräften hab
einfach oben drei holz hin und dann
unten 2 kopp ist offen
ich kann mal wieder zurückgelaufen ich
kein gehör
bitte lasst mich cool finden ich werde
es mir coli wir uns erst mal kohle für
mich ist auch ein bisschen ungewohnt
verein der eigentlich sein ganzes
youtube beleben die spd greift gezockt
hat das texture pack ist die vorfreude
ist natürlich war ein bisschen ungewohnt
für mich fast wie expert aber okay wir
machen hier ist so viel kohle ist so
viel kohle ja ich hab die cola dh es
wird dir empfehlen mich nicht mehr zu
nicht hatten und er töte dich echt ist
er stark
vielleicht gehe ich dann irgendwann mal
reisen ja ich altere weise gefunden ja
wir haben auch schon
nein sagt
essen vorbei das braten wir dann und
diesem alter alter ich hatte schon
wieder geräusche kommen
ich habe es auf gesammelt doch die kohle
vor allen dingen ja ich hab alles zack
zack zack zack zack zack
jetzt gibt es etwas zu essen gibt es ja
ich nehme ich meine aber wir brauchen
vielleicht hören das war mir schon
phrasen
ich muss zum einen auf ihn warten darauf
klicken nicht eigentlich so
wir müssen nicht unbedingt auch ein
cooles schwer machen
ich kann diesen schwer machen eben ein
bisschen kohle
ich mach dir so ein episches schwerter
sich auf hat was besser ankommt was
alles an das ist was jetzt mache ich
schon besser ist ein diamant wird was du
jetzt die gegner fast ohne rüstung auch
mal ein bisschen was mit vielen zwei
teile die ich dafür brauche ich zwei
teile
wir können auch direkt an allen hemd
machen junge junge
es gibt jetzt ganz schön was zu essen
alte alte alte alte alter
hast du das team rausgeholt gib mir das
sofort bitte hier walter nein ich war
recht meine ersten folge gibt ja ich
will schnell du wirfst verwandten bittet
muss ich aufpassen
wir können nicht rausgehen
wir können auf keinen vorausgehen ich
freue mich jetzt für geräusche
ich freue mich jetzt ein
ich habe extra leben alte wie geil bis
zu 30 extra leben haben alter leute ist
das geil bitte komm ich hörte wie
monster geräusche ja ich hab dazu gebaut
aber es klappt alter war das knapp
gerade eben dem keeper junge junge
tomaten
ach diese komischen das ist xps gold
gilt dass eure friedens bereich darf man
nicht in dem gebäude darf man keinen
angreifen dann kannst du was verkaufen
so weit ich weiß ja vielleicht stellen
wir den leuten kurzform 1 abonnenten
wer wie das ganze aufgebaut es gibt zwei
regionen die konkurrieren
ich bin in der wüstenregion mit marius
und fabi ist da minecraft 05 und wer es
noch da ex dennis dennis noch einmal
kurz alex bahr
denn hast du hast eine rüstung aber ich
töte gab so viele sind es gewesen
und warum ist der alte könig kurz
angreifen
ich finde so ungewollt obwohl wir zu
sprinten
ich mach dich zu hit du machst einfach
12 schaden halte was ihr als rumliegt
etwas meinte einfach überhaupt hier sind
aber man sieht es ja alte okay das
zuckerrohr riskieren will kühe haben
ich war kannst du überhaupt nicht
einschätzen wie zocken auf hart kommt
und ich weiß wirklich nicht wie stark
die modische lockhart gestellt dann ist
es weiter ich habe gerade den miesen
hier müssen doch irgendwo bist überhaupt
kann ich irgendwie finden ich bin also
im wald drin party monsters wie sich
erstmal waypoint das haus ein
die welt ist so große gefährlichen ball
zu patrick gruber alter mieter das ist
solist was hier abgeht ist und
bilderrahmen einfach aus dem nichts
bilderrahmen ja klar alte der frost
alter diese fristen stark die sind fast
herr pastilla viele leben ja aber die
sind trotzdem ich fast gar nicht treffen
also wenn du dich treffen bis zu fassen
tot aber gott die altenburger alter ich
bin in der bude komplette herr gib mir
das schwer
ich wusste nicht dass die apu schieben
was los hätte wusste nicht dass die
après ski
ich kann deine sache alter alter siehst
du dich flachsen ich kann deine sachen
ich habe gar nichts scheiße da steckt so
ich ja und die hat fabia die von
umgebunden
leider habe ich habe einst angegriffen
aber erscheint uns angreift kommen beide
auf dich und du warst du gar nicht nur
vorbereitete ja genau weil ich mal dann
haben die weise weg gewohnt haben wir
ein bisschen google tools so also ich
muß schon mal eine folge beenden
ja das denn dass ich regel hier in
behindert kann aachen nur so kann man
sich immer sterbe brave café meine
freunde ich habe ich hatte das video
gefallen kommentare wie das gleiche gilt
auch leute falls ihr experten in website
wisst was ich mir kräften soll schreibt
ihnen die kommentare ich brauche eure
hilfe
ich könnte mir zusammen schaffen reisen
im alter so viel eisen ja ja ja ich
mache auf jeden fall bin ich richtig
wissen ich wollte unbedingt kühl haben
den fa nachts raus gerannt
richtig alt
natürlich man das ist die alte du hast
bestimmt ewig wie minecraft singleplayer
gespielt als oberste regel am anfang ich
nachts raus gehen egal ich hab nur
logisch dass immer wieder
schwierigkeiten augen knochen aber du
wolltest du viel nur das alter ich traue
dem braten ja auch kein bisschen zu
stellen welche hersteller sondern ganz
ehrlich ist mir egal
weiter wie viel eisen habe mit alter
okay wir locker genug dem locker genug
für vollere wo wir sind wir raus sind
wir sind wir uns sicher prioritären
verloren wo michael lang hatte ich kann
einfach gar nicht springt mit doppel-
oder ja dass ich los
ich komme nie wieder doch klar alter
mann im alter ich hasse es
ich verliere immer sofort die
orientierung glaub ich meinen nächsten
folgen nicht zu sterben
ojo ja wir sind bei 18 minuten genau wir
warten noch kurz bisher das eisen fertig
kreisend ist und dann einfach zwei von
iittala verrückt bin so wie du bist du
niemals am anfang lag arion anhängig
heißt also kann ich nicht anziehen
das geht ja gar nicht auf rechts wegen
dieser angebote sind so viele sachen die
ich einfach gar nicht weiß
aber okay es geht jetzt ging es gerade
mit hunger wenn man nicht rum läuft geht
das volk ja auf jeden fall was ich sagen
wollte es geht darf man niemals im
clarion 1
ein zweites leben steht das heißt la
cognac und holen dann ja draußen frost
aber ich weiß gar nicht mehr angegriffen
zu werden
ich dachte muss aber ich weiß hat wurde
zu alles klar
alles klar so 7 eisen your life ist in
kressbronn eines notfallplans unser
leben science mehr gewonnen das ist
schon toll gefühlt regeneriert gut ach
ja und immer wenn du im fight das musst
du dir auch zu nutzen machen wenn du
siehst dass du kurz vom level up ist
also kurz davor wissen
weiters herz zu bekommen also du kannst
nicht mehr warten
aber wenn ich mal kurz zuvor bist dein
leben wird komplett aufgefüllt wenn du
ein neues herz bekommen
das sind sie für geräusche sind für
geräusche julie frost 80 leben
wie viel schaden machen frost überlebe
ich das gemacht
ich glaube es nämlich die kunst ist
etwas anderes ist sowieso ein clever
clever clever an ihrer spitze waren
differenzen bitte es sogar es gibt so
viele neue sachen leute wenn ihr bock
drauf habt dann neigt die folge zu tode
neigt die zu tode
wenn ihr mehr von diesem projekt sehen
wollt dann sage mal versucht mal 150
likes zu schaffen
bei 150 likes dann rast ich voll haus
dann will ich achte kind ist die gesamte
region auf einmal ist der wirklichkeit
versuch das mal ein forum zu zeigen und
das hilfsprojekt weiter wollte natürlich
bringen also 150
ich glaube ich werde das ja vielleicht
auf ich mache meinen letzten tagen
konnte ich ja nicht jeden tag der videos
machen aber ich werde keine ahnung ist
doch geil da muss ich nicht muss ich mir
nicht aussuchen habe ich hätte das ist
sowieso viel erfasst als es eigentlich
lustiger als ender games oder cyber
games wenn ich ab und zu auch noch
machen klar
keine frage aber das wird jetzt auf
jeden fall weit
oft kommen oft bald nein-parole bald nur
oft aber die rüstungs punkte sind ein
bisschen seltsam
ich habe ich hab jetzt ich hab jetzt in
der jazz parade einen helm und eine
leggins ein und hat drei auf zweieinhalb
rüstungs punkte
aber alle sachen die ich finde hier rein
ich habe nämlich von spinnen auge ach
guck box office nämlich stieg die flut
in flash
ja ja das sind sich die sounds sind
ricky alter wo krass was seltsam seltsam
vielleicht habt ihr ne alle wo die
herkommen ich werde jetzt einfach mal
aus mach ich wollte erstmal newton und
filme gucken wo das herkommt in der
nächsten folge
wir machen jetzt wir brauchen aber noch
bild die man so schnell zeigt so dahin
haben wir viele leute und einem schwert
noch machen ja mal ich mach euch an
euren support wie du sagst sport 1 alben
sport ja leute das immer so viele reisen
schwert im billing wenn euch die folge
gefallen hat wie gesagt die last einen
like da ich werde wirklich geil 150
geschaffen
aber das war super da würde ich mich
total feiern ist beschied wir erst noch
schnell import shop und ja wie gesagt
man muss in der beschreibung es werden
aufnahmen mit auch vielen anderen kommen
zum beispiel parteien leute in meiner
region sind sowie ihrer dennis ihn kennt
ihr alle schon genau und zwar das
natürlich auch wichtig dass wussten also
aber okay ja gut dann alter mord nein
als shrek ist so ein frust ein frohes
komplette frust macht dich tot
yo yo yo als richtig cool hier alter
alter ja was sich da noch was uns
gerettet
okay ich hab nur den ton ausgemacht und
dass deswegen habe ich nicht gehört dass
das ding auf mich geschossen hat und ich
sehe was mir vorbei fliegen und schreckt
so zusammen alter
dann muss man ja darf man nicht mehr
weiter aufnehmen wird ihm keiner ab
nutzbare aber also leute wie gesagt wird
sich gefallen hat dann liegt da schreibt
in die kommentare
die tipps anmerkung und ideen die ihr
habt und dann würde ich sagen macht's
gut
haut rein und bis zur nächsten folge
wollte